Well, once again, I recommend getting started by drawing the finite state machine.
So on a or on b, we go over to state 2,
and we could end there because this is optional,
or on c or d, we could go to state 3 and end there.
Here at the top, I've encoded the edges from state 1 on a we go to state 2.
From state 1 on b, we go to state 2 as well--a or b.
From state 2 on c, we go to state 3.
From state 2 on d, we go to state 3.
And both states, 2 and 3, are accepting.
Then down here, I have 3 test cases.
"ac" which should be accepted.
"aX" which should not. X has no business in this regular expression.
And just "b" alone, which should be fine because the c - d part is optional.
Let's go see.
And we get exactly the output we were expecting--true, false, true.
Now you might have been tempted to have a c - d self-loop back to 2,
instead of this right-hand side of the finite state machine.
However, this self-loop changes the meaning to "[a - b][c - d]*".
If you have this self-loop, acc is accepted--a-c-c, and it shouldn't be,
so the self-loop is not the right way to go.